to the White House now where President
Biden and house Speaker Kevin McCarthy
discussed the upcoming Showdown over the
federal debt limit this was at a meeting
yesterday a few hours after FBI agents
searched Mr Biden's vacation home in
Southern Delaware for any documents
marked classified this was the third
location they've searched and this time
according to the president's lawyers
they did not find any documents more
classified is at the White House for us
following all this Ouija good morning
good morning to you Tony and good
morning to everybody President Biden's
legal team also stressing that all three
searches were consensual because
President Biden is fully cooperating
with the investigation but there are
some unanswered questions still about
why the White House did not keep the
public in the loop after vowing to be
transparent
FBI agents with top security clearance
spent Wednesday morning scouring
President Biden's Rehoboth Beach
vacation home for three and a half hours
they did not find any classified
materials but the president's personal
attorney said the FBI did take some
materials and handwritten notes from his
time as vice president former FBI
official Tom O'Connor says agents are
methodical when carrying out this type
of search potentially they could find
something that someone didn't realize
was classified or uh you know notes such
as this which they would not have
thought would have been classified CBS
News was first to report that the FBI
searched the president's former private
office in mid-november the White House
did not disclose that to the public look
I think we're providing information as
this goes on and answering questions
about the the search activities as
they've been happening
at the White House President Biden
ignored questions about the documents
earlier Mr Biden hosted house Speaker
Kevin McCarthy in the Oval Office as a
deadline to raise the debt ceiling draws
closer Republicans say they won't do it
without an agreement to cut spending but
the White House says it's not up for
debate I thought was a very good
discussion and we we walked out saying
we would continue the discussion and I
think there is an opportunity here
come to an agreement on both sides
or right after that meeting the White
House issued a statement repeating that
the obligation to raise the debt ceiling
is not negotiable or conditional
treasury secretary Janet Yellen has said
that despite taking Extraordinary
Measures she expects the U.S will hit
the debt ceiling in early June something
economists say will be catastrophic for
the economy David
Ouija Jang at the White House thank you
Ouija